[Musique]
démilitarisé
dont les russes envahissent lui craindre
dans la nuit du 24 février mélanie joly
est chez elle à montréal avec son
conjoint je me sentais tellement
privilégié d'être de l'autre bord de
l'atlantique chez nous
puis série mondiale
puis là ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'à
trois ans et demi du matin on m'a appelé
puis on m'a dit
on a perdu la connexion satellite on
n'est pas capable de voir tout d'avoir
accès à toute l'information savoir où
les missiles sont lancés
donc c'est plus sécuritaire d'acquitter
la première décision que le ministre
prend en temps de guerre c'est de
redonner aux diplomates canadiens de
quitter l'ukraine elle doit ensuite
proposer des sanctions à imposer à la
russie nous imposons des nouvelles
sanctions visant toutes les grandes
banques russes de faire en sorte de
mettre la pression sur poutine et que le
peuple russe manifeste son
mécontentement
la puissance militaire et économique du
canada est marginal on n'a pas beaucoup
de moyens pour aider l'ukraine à gagner
la guerre ou à faire vraiment mal à la
russie avec des sanctions alors il nous
reste les pressions politiques mais
mélanie joly a rompu ses relations
diplomatiques avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov pourquoi parce que cette
guerre là avant d'arriver à une solution
diplomatique a gagné sur le terrain et
les les russes présentement ne répondent
que par la force et donc pour ça que le
canada est un des premiers pays à
pousser les autres pays pour envoyer de
l'artillerie
il ya dix jours la ministre rencontrait
à ottawa l'ambassadrice du canada en
ukraine pour planifier une visite à kiev
et la réouverture de l'ambassade qu'est
ce que tu entends
de kiev gens donc chaque jour le normal
est en train d'être rétablir
les magasins
les salons de beauté
les ambassades les autres ambassades et
sont tous là
quand elle est au pays la chef de la
diplomatie canadienne revient chez elle
ou si souvent possible moi j'ai un grand
buzz droit d'avoir un hippie que les
choses soient organisées maintenant
c'est gérer le stress gérer
l'anxiété c'est ça mon défi quand je
veux se présenter à la mairie à l'époque
puis je faisais de l'anxiété je
comprenais pas qu'est ce qui se passait
mais maintenant je sais que j'ai besoin
d'aller courir je le sais que j'ai
besoin aussi de m'amuser de pouvoir
décrocher si vous êtes à cuba ou si vous
avez delà de la famille des proches
d'enfants à cuba c'est au peuple est mis
en valeur la ministre réagit ici à la
nouvelle d'une explosion dans un hôtel à
la havane
cela fait partie de son mandat de gérer
les services consulaires quand survient
une tragédie une catastrophe naturelle
ou un conflit armé
j'ai passé au début de la semaine de
rejoindre rendez vous pour la biométrie
pour ma grand mère et de ma famille
pendant trois jours j'ai regardé à tous
les 30 minutes et avait absolument rien
donné depuis deux mois on les a vu des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés sont
allés cogner aux portes des ambassades
du canada dans les pays voisins de
l'ukraine des porte souvent fermés dans
tous les sens du terme comment est ce
que la ministre réagit quand elle voit
son propre ministère ne pas être à la
hauteur des besoins je t'ai extrêmement
fâché mais c'est pour ça que j'ai paraît
manquer c'est inacceptable écoutez là on
le savait qu'elle avoir plusieurs
millions de crédits
[Musique]
c'est parti ça va oui
la première chose nouvelle la journée
c'est encore toutes les questions de
droit vont beaucoup de tirs de missiles
à la vie
je pense que tu es
[Musique]
il ya eu des frappes hier aviv et il y
en a eu encore sorti bon je te demande
comment ça va
moi ce que je vais pas cesser la
reconstruction mélanie joly s'est
entouré de femmes une sous-ministre une
chef de cabine une chef adjointe une
directrice des politiques une autre aux
communications et plusieurs conseillère
politique dans le domaine des mines un
département est en train d'acheter ces
programmes je pense que vous êtes au
courant mais c'est la sensibilisation
risques et qui est présenté à l'aaas
moment ce serait la toute première fois
de l'histoire comptant deux femmes de
pouvoir participer à la gestion d'une
guerre mélanie joly dit qu'elle
collabore très étroitement avec ses
homologues de la grande-bretagne de
l'allemagne tout récemment nommé aux
affaires étrangères est ce que ces
femmes changent vraiment la nature de la
réponse qu'on donne aux conflits en
ukraine certainement on pense pas comme
les hommes mais en quoi on va c'est
différent c'est le niveau d'empathie de
sensibilité par rapport à la réalité des
femmes et les enfants
à travers ces images d'enfants et deux
mamans qui fuient les bombes bouleverse
la ministre jolie peut-être encore plus
parce qu'elle désire fonder une famille
la politicienne qui à 43 ans a failli
refuser sa nomination aux affaires
étrangères
j'étais pas convaincu que
c'était le temps pour moi d'être de
venir mener ses affaires étrangères
parce que je voulais avoir un enfant et
j'étais préoccupé que le fait de voyager
autant m'empêcherait de devenir maman le
ministre parle ouvertement de ses
traitements de fécondation in vitro une
démarche difficile surtout s'il faut la
conjuguer avec de nombreux voyages et
une gestion de crise sans précédent
mélanie joly croit-elle toujours pouvoir
gérer une guerre tout en devenant maman
j'ai assez parlé d'eux
mais
ça fait des années qu'un ministre des
affaires étrangères pas gérer une guerre
n'est jamais eu de mise affaires
étrangères condé
enfin marqué aucun jeune enfant ont été
les premières à tous
[Musique]